each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
he's a PhD student at university of
washington and and he has done some
interesting work on problems to get a
business and he'll be talking about the
same thanks so i'm gonna talk about my
dissertation work or an aspect of my
dissertation work in managing large
scale probabilistic databases and before
i get started just feel free to ask
questions during the talk at any time I
don't mind it makes it more entertaining
for me so if anything is unclear or you
just want to poke fun of me just raise
your hand or something Thanks okay so
let me give you the one slide overview
of what I'm up to so today applications
are driven by data and increasingly that
data is large and in precise so let me
give you three examples of this the
first example is sensor data this data
is in precise because we're trying to
measure the physical world and whenever
we're try to measure the physical world
we have things like measurement error
which is necessarily in precise a second
example our business intelligence
applications here imagine a competitor
of something like the kindle two so some
competitor of amazon they want to know
how well the kindle two is doing in the
marketplace so one way to do this is to
go in extract posts from news and blogs
and things like that extract some facts
and then do some complex analytic
wearing on top of them now the problem
is that that step of extracting facts is
necessarily in precise a third and more
classical example is data integration
here we have two databases that talk
about the same real world entities but
the way in which they refer to those
entities is different so we have two
options we could make sure that all the
references are consistent which is a
very expensive task of data cleaning or
as myself and some others have advocated
we can tolerate some imprecision during
the merge and thereby lower the cost of
data cleaning or data integration now in
each of these applications this is the
kind of data we'd like to manage in a
database maybe a streaming database
maybe a relational database we want
things that the database would provide
like rich structured query but the
problem is that current databases are
precise they can't understand the
imprecisely man Tex of the data that
we're talking about so in this talk I'm
going to tell you about my work which is
databases that can manage large in
precise collections of data and the way
that we're going to model that
imprecision in my work specifically is
using probabilities now probabilities
are great they give us a uniform way to
talk about all those different kinds of
imprecision so we can get to the
fundamental data management issues but
there's a cost to using them as well
when we go to do things like answer a
query we have to combine all of these
different alternatives and this is much
more difficult than standard relational
processing so the challenge I'm going to
talk to you about here is about handing
managing the performance of rich
structured queries on probabilistic data
and that's going to be the focus of our
talk okay so first what I'm going to
talk about our three emphasized atta
based applications in a little bit of
detail so you can see both how the data
look like and what the queries look like
and what the actual imprecision we're
modeling is then I'll tell you a bit
about managing relational probabilistic
databases which really forms the core of
my dissertation and resulted in a system
mystic which is the screenshot on the
side okay then if we have time also tell
you about some other systems that I
built including one for streaming
probabilistic data and some things some
other side projects then I'll talk about
future work and also my vision for the
future of data management and finally
conclude so let's talk about those in
precise data based applications well the
first one I want to tell you about is
RFID so RFID is a technology that lets
you track objects as they move through
space okay originally RFID was used to
track things in supply chains like you
have a palette of 30 mach3 sitting in
your warehouse but recently people have
realized that RFID enables much richer
applications for example equipment
traffic tracking and hospitals okay so
we want to build applications on this
kind of RFID data and the kind of things
we want to do our answer structured
queries like alert me when Joe enters
422 now what you see on your screen here
is a deployment that we'd like to answer
this query over an RFID deployment a
through E signify the readers right and
Joe our little good husky wearing purple
in the bottom has a tag on him an RFID
tag and the idea is that when he walks
by one of those readers he'll be read
the system will know where he is and
hopefully we'll be able to answer this
query
so an ideal system it would look
something like this Joe walks out of the
Joe walks out of the room and he walks
down the hallway and as he walked down
the hallway you can see that his
readings are recorded in this table and
when he enters 422 we hope the system
says Joe entered room 422 at time T
equals 7 you can imagine that the way
the system would do this is that well it
didn't see him at antenna E and it
reasons that perhaps you know he went
into 422 this is the ideal picture this
is where we'd like to get now
unfortunately the challenge we're going
to face is that these data is actually
in precise and it's in precise for three
reasons the first reason is that readers
are not in all areas of interest so in a
little cartoon example you see that
there are readers in a through E but
they're not in 422 right and you can
imagine in real deployments like for
example in a hospital you can't put a
reader inside the intensive care unit
there's just the equipment in there is
very sensitive and not shielded so
you'll always have some areas that are
off-limits to these readers a second
challenge and a little bit more subtle
is that there's an abstraction mismatch
so you see the kind of data we get from
the deployment Joe's tag is read at time
3 by antenna beat by antenna a right
it's at this very low level of
granularity but the queries want to ask
her at a much higher level there are
things about rooms and offices or maybe
I see use ok and it's pretty clear that
there's no one to one mapping between
those antennae readings and actually
which room joe went into right in this
example given that data he could have
just as easily gone into the room with D
in it all right so there's some
ambiguity or imprecision in the data a
third problem is that in real life
deployments like this readings are often
missed so even though we were able to
reason for example that he went into one
of those two rooms because we didn't see
an antenna reading at E the reading at
it could have just been simply missed
and this is actually a real problem in
deployments if the RFID readings touch
your skin are the reader touches your
skin the read rates drop below for
example thirty percent so this is a real
problem as well so what we're going to
do to handle all these things so we can
answer our rich structured queries is
we're going to do some pre-processing
we're going to borrow from the large AI
literature and we're going to build a
probabilistic model that's going to take
in as input these antennae readings and
give us back something at a higher
logical level in terms of offices in
hallways the cost of this transformation
is that now the
going to be in precise and we're going
to have to deal with this imprecision
when we do query processing okay so
let's look in a little bit more detail
what that pre-processing looks like so
what you see on your screen here is a
picture of the sixth floor at the
University of Washington in our computer
science building it's an architectural
diagram there are now some offices and
hallways and the blue lines are
connectivity diagram okay now these
green circles are actually those readers
are antennas that are lighting the
hallway those RFID readers and then as
you see their linings the only some of
the hallways now in the movie that I'm
about to show you this little blue ring
here who represents Joe is going to walk
down the hallway walk into a lab and
walk out the other side okay the thing
to pay attention to is that as he walks
by an antenna the antenna will change
from green to yellow and you'll see that
there'll be some periods of time when
he's actually in the lab that he's not
read by any of these antennas the reason
he's not read by the antennas is well
there are no antennas in the lab so pay
special attention to when he makes that
left turn and go through the lab so here
Joe's walking down the hallway he's read
by one or more readers at each time he
goes into the lab and after a little
while he's not read then he walks down
the other side ok now you can imagine
that those yellow flashes are really the
kind of data we're getting back from the
deployment you can imagine easily how
those yellow flash is translated into
the kind of table that I showed you how
to slide earlier ok so now what we're
going to do is we're going to do some
inference process we're going to try and
go from this low level data those
flashing lights to some higher level
data and the inference mechanism that
i'm going to show you is a very simple
and intuitive one there are alternative
alternative ones and this is a prior art
it's called particle filtering so the
goal of prodigal filtering is to infer
where Joe actually is given some of
those antenna readings ok so these
little orange circles here orange
particles I want you to think about them
as a guess over where Joe actually is
given the antenna readings that you've
seen so far ok so now we'll watch the
movie and see how the particle filters
actually track him and pay special
attention to when they get next to that
lab so you see the particles do a pretty
good job of tracking when there are
sensor readings there's a little
visualizer lag coming up but there you
see that the particles when you go
through that lab when there are no
readings are able to interpolate the
data so some particles went in one lab
and some other set of particles went in
a different lab okay so this is what the
data actually looks like this is what
the probabilistic data actually looks
like so what have we really done here
well we've gone from the low level data
which we're in terms of these antennae
readings and having all those sorts of
imprecision and we've abstracted it up
to get some data that looks like the
data on the right hand side okay for
example each time period we just count
the number of particles that are in an
office or a hallway or so on and now we
have a distribution over logical
locations now looking at that table
we've solved already one of our problems
you can imagine how you would write such
a simple structured query how you would
build a system to process on top of data
that looks like that if it didn't have
that probability attribute that special
semantic attribute okay now the
challenge is going to be that we're
going to take this as input to our
system data that looks like this on the
right hand side and we're going to
process these structured queries and the
challenge is going to be that those
structured queries are going to be
difficult to process because we have to
combine all possible ways of where Joe
was at some time maybe he's in the
office maybe he's in the hallway and so
on okay and we're going to focus on
really efficient processing for that
let me give you a second application of
in precise data that has nothing to do
with physical measurement but where the
data still result in some amount of
imprecision okay so what you see a
picture here is a picture of my itunes
while i'm listening to a jazz song okay
now the interesting part for us is this
right hand side bed over here this is
called the i like sidebar okay i like
calm as a seattle-area startup that some
of you may or may not know that
basically their business models they
want to embed a social network into
itunes okay now we're going to focus on
this side bar so i'm going to zoom in on
it right now the idea of this sidebar
how they're going to make money is that
they're going to recommend things to you
like which shows to see or which songs
you want to buy okay and to do that
they're going to leverage the fact that
you're in bedded in some social network
so here in the social network i can see
for example that some of my friends are
listening to songs and so on and if i
click on this related tab what i can do
is get some songs that related to the
song i happen to be listening to in my
itunes right so that i may buy it for
example so when I click on related what
I get back or a bunch of jazz songs now
the bunch of Jack songs that I get back
that it recommends me as good matches to
the song i'm listening to it's a very
rich similarity it's combined a bunch of
information not only as a combined
effect that i was listening to a jazz
song and those are jazz songs that are
returned but it didn't give me for
example songs that were already in my
library more interestingly it also does
things like look at my friend network
and see what are songs that my friends
have that I don't have now the point of
all this is that it combines a
relatively large amount of data to
compute these rankings and it does it
very very efficiently okay and just to
give it a size of the data there around
30 plus million users of I like right
now it's one of the bigger applications
on facebook so it's a non-trivial amount
of data that they have to crunch to
compete this right to compute this
recommendation now you could certainly
imagine building a one-off matching
engine that would do exactly the
similarity computation but this very
same data that they need to access that
they generated for the similarity
computation their business needs to
access in different ways so they want to
recommend for example which show should
you see this is one of their business
style queries and to do that they need
to ask complex queries that look a lot
like the
on the screen who should I give tickets
to in Lupe Lupe Fiasco tickets to so to
answer this query what they actually
want to do is they want to do some
analytic style queries it's almost OLAP
style queries on top of this data some
ad hoc queries and the point of this is
that there's some value now in DB
integration because they're alternative
approach would be to build sort of
one-off engines to do each of these
tasks that touch the same data now the
point is that we want to support exactly
this kind of integrated querying with
the matching and the similarity and also
these complicated structured queries on
top the challenge for us is how are we
going to process these efficient these
queries efficiently at really large
scales because you see that the data
itself has actually several gigabytes of
data of similarity and friend data and
things like that okay okay let me give
you one last example with a little bit
more detail in it so we can go a little
bit deeper about it this is combining
information extraction and some
deduplication techniques so the
motivating query for this example is we
want to find papers and vldb 2008
written by authors at the University of
Washington okay now one way to answer
this query is to build some extraction
engine and go extract these papers from
people's web pages so imagine we were
able to do that that part perfectly what
we would get out of the information
extraction is a nice structured table
that would tell us for example you know
the title of each paper the author and
the conference and the year right so we
get some nice rich structured
information now if your expert
information extraction you know that
obtaining this table itself is very very
difficult and can also be modeled as in
precise data but I'm going to ignore
that for the moment because I want to
focus on something different so if we
were to take this query and evaluate on
this data we'd face a very very well
known problem even though our query
talks about vldb and the entity vldb is
currently represent is clearly inside of
our data it's actually represented in
two slightly different ways by different
strings right actually in three
different ways so if we post our query
on this on this table naively with a
standard relational engine we would get
no answers so what do we do here we do
the standard thing we compute a fuzzy
joint right so the output of a fuzzy
join the way we what happens is we look
at each pair of stir
and we compute the extent to which
they're similar and the this output of
this fuzzy join we can model as a simple
table here a simple relation and what
we'll do is we'll model that that score
has a probability and I'll come to that
a little bit later but given this data
you can imagine very easily how you
would combine that in certain orem
precise information of similarity to
compute the answer to your query right
you could probably imagine writing some
ad hoc program that's going to combine
scores in some way and and compute an
answer the problem you face is if you
want to write much richer queries right
each time you write these queries if you
don't have a principle semantics you
have to write some new ad hoc program to
do it and it's not clear how you're
going to be able to transfer from one
domain to the next so we want to support
rich structured queries like SQL on top
of this kind of em precise are uncertain
data and again the challenge is going to
be that we want to support these queries
efficiently and we're going to consider
data sets that are large in the sense
that they would be something you would
stick inside a standard relational
engine and now we have to do all this
extra overhead of processing this
uncertainty so that's going to be the
challenge I'm going to talk about today
okay so what I want you to take away
from this application once you take away
three things but two are on the slide
the first is that there are a growing
number of these large and precise data
sets I showed you three examples so far
the second is that in many of these data
sets there's example there's value in
rich structured sequel like wearing on
top of them or at least rich structured
query the third takeaway is that the
challenge we're going to have to deal
with is processing these things
efficiently and we'll get into a little
bit more detail of why this is actually
a very serious challenge but this is the
challenge were going to address the talk
please
I may ask why you think doing this stuff
in a relational database is right let me
give you example um as I understand your
examples you see me putting marginals
into your database the probability of
being unfortunately to given everything
else the probability of this person
likes this music given everything else
well in order to be the structure
queries correctly you have to go back to
the joy that the marginal was computed
from and then do sort of inference or
essentially do summing in different ways
it seems like if you you destroyed a lot
of the information might need to compute
them exactly it's kind of like the same
problem when you compute query plans in
a in a database query itself you only
have certain marginal counts of the
columns you don't have the relationships
between those why is stuffing in today
so it's a great point so the the way i
would say your point is i haven't shown
you the model yet the public model yet
but you are correct that is a very
simplified model compared to something
that you would find in the graphical
model literature or the statistic
literature that can model the kind of
rich correlations you're talking about
the spin that we're putting on this or
what we want to do is we want to model
relatively simple correlations and focus
on the query processing so the query
processing will be correct that would be
the contract the question you ask is how
well does the model for example
information extraction model match the
model the contract I'm going to provide
for you in a few slides and I'll show
you I'll show you that model in a little
bit and we can have a more technical
discussion then but the point that I
want to make is that there are a lot of
applications where you can do very
interesting things inside the simplified
model so you're absolutely right there's
some information loss going from the
rich information extractor model CRF
model into the simplified model I'm
going to tell you about with just
marginals but it's unclear to me that
that modeling those extra correlations
will buy you all that much for the kinds
of queries we're looking at so once I
get to the end and talk about this
project and also talk about another
project I'll be more than happy to have
a debate about where the rich is the
model question falls in in these systems
but it's an excellent point and it's
something we're very much aware of but
yes so what I'm going to focus on for
the rest of this for at least the next
little few slides is what a generic
system would look like and the
fundamentals that we have to do to do
the
ausa Singh assuming you've gotten the
data into the model that i'll tell you
about and maybe five slides okay so let
me just give you to be a little bit more
concrete let me just give you a picture
of how a generic system would look like
so we'll go back to that information
extraction example where we have the
probabilities and we have the original
data maybe this data itself is actually
emphasized now the way you would use
this with our system and the system like
mystic is that you would take the data
and load it into a standard database
okay now the problem with doing this
loading is that the data is the database
is not aware of the semantics it's not
aware of that special key column over
there this probability column so what
we're going to propose is that you'll
use mystic our system to query the data
to interpret and understand the this
probability Colin and process the
queries correctly so here's a screenshot
of mystic okay what it gives you is an
interface where you can write SQL
queries and get back some results now
the query that's actually written here
is exactly that query that we've been
informally discussing so far on the talk
find papers and vldb written by authors
at the University of Washington the
point is is that you can imagine writing
almost arbitrary SQL here and getting
back answers that's the kind of
interface we want to provide to this
data set now how do we use those
probabilities those marginal
probabilities we use them to rank the
answers the answers that come back from
the database so each each tuple now is
not precise it's not in the answer not
in the answer it's only in the answer
with some score some probability the
marginal probability it appears in the
answer and we're going to pick to give
back to the user the most important of
those marginal probabilities okay are
the highest valued probabilities okay
and in this way we've traded the fact
that we didn't get any answers we've
increased the recall at the expense of
some precision here okay so that's how
we're getting back more answers now now
this should also point out why ranking
is such a fundamental thing because
we're always going to use these things
to rank them and so we'll see in a
little bit about how to compute the top
ones efficiently okay okay
alright so now I've gone through the
motivation now I'm going to talk a
little bit about actually a relational
probabilistic data this is the kind of
data that I've been showing you so far
on the talk and the fundamental
techniques you need to scale up two
gigabytes of data so the model that we
use is a very simple model goes back to
at least 1992 Barbara at all and the way
I read this this database is that it's a
database that contains two entities okay
there's an entity that is PDB that was
for sure published in 2008 but we're
uncertain about whether or not it was
published in vldb or whether was
published in Sigma okay was published in
one of the two but we don't know which
the extent to which we believe that it
was published in vldb is exactly 0.62 ok
this is the since it's a high score we
think it's more likely that there's
published in vldb then it was published
in sigmod independently from that
there's a second entity in the data
uncertainty bees which was published in
1992 and you see here that there are
three alternatives for for this database
and above and below the line we're going
to assume these are independent for
example if they're independent
extractions so it's a very simplified
model of the database please yes so he
does it so we don't insist that they add
up to one the probabilities add up to
one and I'll show you on the next slide
essentially when it doesn't add up to
one this is the probability you can
think of that it was a bogus extraction
and it's also just a simplified thing in
the model so that p is a special thing
that's basically these marginal
probabilities but now i'm going to show
you what it actually means okay so what
it means is the standard thing it's a
distribution over possible worlds or
just discrete probability distribution
so in the entity as raghav correctly
pointed out there we allow the
possibility that for example p DBS was
not present at all so there are three
alternatives for PD bees similarly there
are four alternatives for uncertainty
bees and since all combinations are
possible there are twelve possible
world's here corresponding to all the
choices that we could make so each one
of those choices will refer to as a
possible world and here's one possible
world pdb we chose that it's in dl DB
and uncertainty bees we chose that it
was an ICD the weight of that world we
compute because we've assumed
independence we simply multiply the
probabilities the marginal probabilities
okay now in this way we can get
distribution over all 12 such possible
worlds so every choice for example there
was a world that just glossed over click
twice for example if there's no world we
use the one- complement okay so the
point of this is that very easily we
think about this database as
representing exactly this distribution
so it's written down exponentially more
succinctly but this is really what the
data means it's this collection over
possible worlds with some associated
marginal probabilities now the nice
thing about this semantics is you know
it's well-founded so it immediately
gives us a semantics for any kind of
query any kind of boolean query and the
semantics for a boolean query or more
concretely that score that comes back
with a toppling mystic is exactly the
marginal probability that something is
true so for example if we wanted to
process the query that PDP's was in vldb
and uncertain databases was not in pods
we would go back to those 12 world
semantically and check on each one does
it satisfy the query is the query true
on this world so on the first world the
query is true so we're going to keep it
similarly in the second world it's true
so we'll keep that as well on the third
world it's not true because the second
database uncertainty Beezus and pods and
we'll throw it away so in this way we
can again semantically anyway go through
all 12 possible worlds and compute
exactly the marginal probability that
this query is true so it gives us a nice
well-founded semantics now if you're
clever and you looked at this you could
say well you told me it was independent
you could just compute them directly
from those marginal probabilities over
there multiply P 1 times 1 minus p 5 and
be done and what this points out is that
we don't always have to go through this
exponential blow-up to compute those
probabilities and of course that's what
we're going to want to do okay whenever
possible we're not going to want to go
through this expensive process of going
through all the exponential in many
worlds to compute a query answer okay so
go through there okay so at this point
you may be thinking well maybe the
queries are simple and we'll be able to
always be able to compute it by just
multiplying probabilities because you
know the model is so simple and maybe
you think sequel queries are so simple
but in fact it turns out that they're
sharp be hard to compute these queries
or np-hard so even though the model is
very simple for very small sizes of
queries actually it turns out to be
intractable theoretically anyway to
compute queries on this okay so for the
experts in the room what I mean is for
conjunctive queries when I say xq el
confer conjunctive queries the data
complexity is sharp be hard for these
queries so they are theoretically quite
difficult to deal with even in this
already simplified model now you may be
thinking well we're sunk at this point
because you know it's it's just as hard
as inference it's NP hard or sharpy hard
what are we really bought by this model
but it turns out that actually the
queries that we want to evaluate can be
well approximated by sampling okay so
for the experts in the room what I mean
is that there's a an FP trois a fully
polynomial time randomized approximation
scheme which can compute exactly those
scores so when every when every couple
comes back there's some sampling routine
that's guaranteed to be efficient to
compute those scores in theory now it's
efficient in theory but actually in
practice it's about one to two orders of
magnitude slower than standard SQL
processing okay and this is one of the
things that we're going to try and
address in this talk we're going to talk
about how to mitigate the expense of
this sampling so that we can run almost
as fast as standard relational
processing that would be the gold
standard that's what we're after okay
but we're up against something hard here
right theoretically these queries are
much harder to evaluate than standard
relational queries so now I can talk
about my dissertation contributions
essentially the mystic system that I
just showed you is the first large-scale
probabilistic relational database and
prior art was dealing with hundreds or
tens of thousands of tuples with limited
queries but in this work what I'm going
to show you is how we can handle rich
structured queries on billions of tuples
and that number is meant to be shocking
because even sequel databases will have
trouble with billions of tuples right so
the fact that we can deal with this on
probabilistic databases means that we're
doing something interesting here okay
please still some temples deliver rely
on top K across the same force phone
number okay
so exact so they're going to see in a
second when I gave you the technical
contributions that we're going to have
basically two main technical things that
I'll talk about to get there one is
going to be top K processing so if your
query is only looking for those top 5 or
10 answers we're going to leverage that
to not run the simulation to compute all
those probabilities and I'll get into
that in some detail the second thing
we're going to worry about is
pre-computation to scale up to really
these these billion size databases and
what's going to happen there is that
we're going to use materialized views
and those are the two contributions
another thing that we can use to scale
up to these large data sets are
compression okay so because it's a job
talk I have to hit you over the head
with something what I'm going to hit you
over the head with is the theme of my
work right so what I'm going to talk
about and I'm going to highlight with
these little reddish and bluish colors
here or that we're going to do some
formal work for practical results okay
and so the red box will show whenever
there's a theory result in the blue box
will show whenever there's a practical
result so will be impossible to miss
miss because i'll mention it again when
it happens okay so that should be fun
for everyone to look for okay so let's
get into those technical contributions I
was talking about essentially for
relational data there are four main
parts of my dissertation for relational
data ok so for relational data as
Christian mentioned there's this top K
processing that I'm going to get into
some detail because it has nice pictures
then I'm going to talk a little bit
about materialized views less nice
pictures but a little bit theoretically
deeper and then there are these other
two which are approximate lineage in
aggregate processing and due to time
constraints and attention spans there's
no way I'm going to go into them but if
you want to ask me about then I'm more
than happy to talk about them so i'll
try and give one sentence summaries at
the end ok so the first one I want to go
into is this top K processing let me
motivate this problem for you remember
we relax the database right we allowed
more matches to our queries and we were
going to score them but when we allowed
more matches we allowed a lot more
matches right and we will only want to
show the user for example the top five
this is very natural think about Google
you enter in a keyword query there are
billions of hits or billions of related
documents and you really only want that
top five or ten to look at so top K is a
natural thing to study here so what
we're going to do sorry what we're going
to do is try and find that top K
efficiently okay because we have this
very very
of sampling routine that we want to
optimize so to to state the result what
I want to do is give you a very
simplified model of sampling that
actually holds up well in practice okay
so we can how I want you to think about
sampling so the way to think about
sampling is that we want to compute for
each one of those papers that comes back
that marginal probability that score and
that scores the piz I'm denoting with P
here sits somewhere between zero and one
right now we don't know where P is if we
knew where P is we'd be done we could
just you know sort them and rank them by
probability the game is going to be to
try and find out where P lives now
initially p lives somewhere between zero
and one and one out how I'm going to
illustrate that graphically is an
interval that spans the entire distance
between zero and one now the way I want
you to think about sampling is that
we're going to run iterations sampling
iterations and our uncertainty is going
to shrink okay so as we run an
increasing number of simulations that
sampling out where the most telling you
about our uncertainty about where p
lives is getting smaller one other thing
about the way we're going to model
sampling is that in fact the intervals
will be nested now if you're an expert
in Monte Carlo sampling you know this
doesn't actually hold for general
montecarlo sampling the intervals are
not nested like this but we show that in
fact you can view you can view them as
being nested with just a little bit of
slop ok so the mental model I want you
to have is I run more simulations and
these intervals shrink in a nested way
okay always containing the true
probability okay so let's consider
what's a naive method for top k well
let's say I want to process this top two
papers that were in vldb 2008 by authors
at the University of Washington so here
are some paper titles that would be
returned by sort of the standard
relational answers and what I want to
computer their scores those p values so
initially when the database returns I
have no idea where p lives right so
every couple has an interval that spans
all of 0 & 1 no idea where P is for any
temple now naively what i could do is
simulate each interval until it's small
right spend a bunch of its when to spend
a bunch of simulations until they're all
small and then it becomes very easy to
rank them right because they become very
small and i can get the top two right
but notice that I wasted a bunch of
effort computing precisely the
probabilities of four and three really
reducing their intervals when all i was
after were the top two okay so the
question that i'm going to ask now is
can we do better and of course this is a
job talk and it would make for quite an
awkward job talk at the answer where no
so I'll spoil a surprise the answer is
actually yes okay so what does better
look like the picture for better looks
like this will simulate the top one till
it's small again but we won't waste much
time simulating the second one and the
fourth one will let them be large okay
and we'll let them be just small enough
that we can that we can prove that we
found for example the top two okay and
here we will have saved lots of work and
we save lots of work because we didn't
reduce either of those two intervals so
this is the kind of mental model that we
want for the multi simulation algorithm
so now i'm going to show you an
algorithm that can achieve can try and
achieve a picture that looks more like
this now to get there what we need is
this notion that we call the critical
region the idea is that we want to have
a region so actually i'll just make this
a dry definition so the critical region
for k equals 2 is graphically
illustrated on the screen okay it's the
Cape I as left endpoint and the k plus
first highest right endpoint okay so
there's the right endpoint the third
highest right endpoint and the second
highest left endpoint okay so this is
just a critical region very dry boring
definition now the reason that we care
about the critical region is because if
we were to run those simulations what it
encodes is effectively whether or not
we're done okay so if we as you can see
if we run a bunch of simulations and in
fact we've separated the top two of the
line then it's always the case that the
second highest left endpoint will be
higher than the third highest right
endpoint okay so the critical region is
just basically formalizing this region
that we care about okay when it's empty
we're done we found the top two now what
we're going to use it for is that I'm
going to now show you a series of
pictures that look like this that are a
picture of the critical region and
basically the algorithm is going to say
which interval do I simulate next I'm
going to pick that interval run a
simulation it's going to get a little
bit smaller and then we're going to you
know look at more pictures and again so
that's the way the algorithms
new phrase look at a picture which
interval do I simulate next it's going
to be a very simple algorithm so the
first rule that we need is what we call
always pick a double-crosser okay so if
there's a double-crosser here's a
double-crosser that means it spans all
the way across the interval then we're
always going to pick this one and the
reason we're going to pick it is because
well you can see that there could only
possibly be one interval that would be
above it and we're looking for the top
two and because the nested assumption
there's no way to get out from
underneath it okay it's actually very
easy to see that in fact one of the
intervals that we need to simulate must
intersect this critical region so it's
got to be overlapping with that guy so
we'll always have to simulate this one
so this is the first one that we pick
the second case is if they're all
one-sided crosses crossers either either
upper or lower crossers so in this case
they're all lower crossers now in this
case we'll simply pick one okay pick a
maximal one now the one we pick is this
maximal one here and the reason that we
pick it is that all these other
intervals are contained underneath it so
no amount of work on these intervals
here will allow us to a sort of escape
from this top maximal one so we would
always have to pick this one as well
okay the third simple rule of the three
is when there are both upper and lower
crossers and in this case we're going to
pick them both okay now those are the
three rules it's a very very simple
algorithm okay one thing to notice
though about this very simple algorithm
is that in each case except for this
last one it seemed like we had to do
what we were we were doing it was the
optimal thing to do but in this example
here it's different because an optimal
algorithm may need to pick only one of
these two so what I'm getting at is that
actually even for this very simple
algorithm we can say something
interesting about its performance
theoretically and practically so in
theory that algorithm I just showed you
under some technical assumptions on any
input those three rules i showed you is
a two approximation meaning that any
other algorithm for the problem does
that most does it most half as many
iterations as the algorithm i showed you
there okay so it's something interesting
we can say the second point is that
actually no deterministic algorithm can
always do better on every instance okay
so in some sense is that very simple
rules
are actually an optimal set of rules for
this problem now theories great but
there's the blue color practice and then
practice remember that we wanted to get
about two orders of magnitude
improvement so we could get close from
in the marketing speak in front speed to
sequel speed okay so now I want to show
you a graph that will explain sort of
how this thing is so so wonderful and is
able to go from you know very large and
running times to very small running
times so here's the practical
performance so what you see on your
screen here is a graph where we're
comparing the naive method against the
multi simulation method on the y axis is
time and log scale ok now the experiment
we ran was actually kind of fun we went
and got and downloaded the IMDb database
when it was still public and well then
we went to the web and downloaded a
bunch of movie reviews ok now we took
these movie reviews and we categorize
them as positive or negative we did some
sentiment analysis on we extracted the
titles from the movie reviews as well
and then we joined them back to the IMDb
database using a fuzzy joint then we
they we got to execute nice rich
structured queries over this over this
data so one example of a rich structured
query would be tell me years in which
anthony hopkins was in a highly rated
movie and you can see that we would have
to join to get the highly rated movie we
would have to touch both the fuzzy join
and the sentiment analysis right and
also do some relational some strong
structure processing on this query now
the point to take away from here is that
you see the query execution time it's
illustrated by the blue part right it's
relatively insignificant is in the same
in our approach as the naive approach
okay the real difference comes in the
red bar that's the sampling time and you
see that the sampling time for the naive
method is only order of a thousand
seconds well we're on the order of about
ten seconds so we have substantial
orders of magnitude improvement by just
looking for that top top 10 or top it
was top 10 in this example okay please
setup of the problem is that certain
that was not on more interesting animals
always the case no certainly not always
the case right you can imagine sort of
debugging applications where you're
looking for rare events especially in
aggregation queries you may be
interested in things that are very
infrequent the model here though is that
we want to get as close to the certain
answers as possible because we want to
get as close to the standard relational
semantics ideally in the system we
should get out of the way so if your
database where certain then it should
return exactly the same tuples and
motivated by that desiderata ranking
them by the most certain is the the most
natural thing to do but it's certainly
not an exhaustive set of semantics like
you can certainly imagine looking for
the rare events or something like this
as well please what are gonna vanity but
so doc it's not one of the common use
and should type thing but I think I
radical is I think some when average
that the sort of optimization
so for some in average queries there's
actually a very interesting technical
difference between them and the queries
we're looking at here we're looking at
these boolean queries essentially you
know for each year did Anthony Hopkins
have a highly rated movie that's a
single tupple and then each year is its
own individual tupple that's the kind of
queries we're running here so admittedly
they're not the OLAP style count sum
average queries one contribution that I
won't have time to talk about is the
classifying exactly those kind of
queries so we call having queries and it
turns out that they have a much more
interesting landscape than the queries
that I'm presenting here in fact this
sampling algorithm doesn't always exist
for them and it requires non-trivial
effort to even get that sampling
algorithm to run but that is definitely
an open area and it's one listed on my
future work sizes some of the ways to
attack in them I'm happy to tell you my
ideas but we haven't done anything yet
we might have some green space
so we leveraged actually here so I
didn't mention this but we since our
tuples are stored in a standard
relational database we have access to
all the persistence durability and
indexing that comes with a standard
database actually examine that actually
every couple is a positive answer I
believe round eight of us there's lots
of you it is certainly true that we will
have a lot more answers than over
standard relational database but we do
benefit from indexing in the actual
relational part of the processing but I
think you're proposing is a more
interesting scheme where you've also
indexed some probability information and
you know that you don't have to retrieve
for example all the possible answers
because you can put on some upper bound
in this work we didn't actually consider
that but for the streaming databases
those RFID databases we actually have an
upcoming icde paper that has a very
similar observation for top k processing
processing there but we'd never applied
it to relational processing it's a good
point other questions so we saw here
that there was about a to order of
magnitude difference between are
approaching the naive approach and the
point 01 f sighs of course what was
hiding behind that white space is that
it can be much much worse okay so here's
a much richer query on the same data
tell me directors with highly rated
movies in the 80s and there are a lot
more directors than there are years that
Anthony Hopkins was in a movie and so
our approach is correspondingly much
better right there are a lot more tuples
to sort through the naive approach has
to sort through all of them tell their
small we can focus in on that top very
quickly and in fact in this example the
naive didn't terminate okay and there
this is actually not uncommon that we
basically go from an interest procedure
that can't terminate to something that
can terminate as long as we have this
top K constraint on so for at least four
top K queries we're in pretty good shape
we can process these about as fast as
relational questioning clearly not as
fast comparing the blue bar to the red
bar but you know it's in the same
ballpark so I've told you about top k
processing what I'm now going to tell
you about is another aggressive strategy
that really allows us to scale up to
huge data sets that we call materialized
views so I'm sure everyone knows this
but materialized views are just the
database way that people are the way
that database people think about caching
okay so let me put my spin on it so what
we want to do and all caching things is
we want to cache or compute something up
front and then use that work that we've
done up front to optimize for example
later queries or to save ourselves later
work ok now the particularly nice spin
that this takes in databases is that we
know precisely how that data is cached
right the materialized view gives us a
view description right which is just a
query that tells us for example exactly
how this database was generated so here
we say you know conference with papers
from u-dub and it generates exactly this
table so that we're going to leverage
that logical view description and what
we'll do is we'll then you know use this
in a standard relational engine will use
this to optimize future queries now in
probabilistic databases things get a
little bit more interesting and the
reason they get more interesting is that
these tuples have a rich or semantics
than standards deterministic couples
they're more akin to things like random
variables so there's some probability
that the topple is present and what that
means is that as everyone knows random
variables can be correlated so these
tuples may be correlated for example the
vldb tuples may be more likely to
co-occur together or less likely to
co-occur together then simply
independent tuples for example so
there's some correlations now the way
that these correlations have been
tracked you know since going back to the
see tables and now with the lineage
approach promoted by trio now these
formulas these lineage formulas which
are written here the land is okay the
way I want you to think about land of
these lineage formulas that they're
boolean formulas that are true precisely
when this tuple is true so for example
vldb 2008 is present precisely when some
type will p1 is present and either q1 or
q2 or present okay and if you want to
know how to compute these I won't go
into semantics but it basically requires
all derivation of tuples in the view
okay now observe here also I just want
to make one little last point observe
that in fact vldb is correlated and the
way they're correlated is because both
of them have this q2 they both rely on
the same couple underneath it which
means that they're not independent okay
so there are some correlations in the
view now what we want to do for
probabilistic materialized views is
compute something up front and again use
it for later query processing so one
naive approach would be to compute
exactly this table here and then use
that to optimize future queries right do
all the inference use all the lineage
formulas and so on
but this doesn't solve the bottleneck
the bottleneck and probabilistic query
processing is not actually computing
these formula it's actually doing the
inference and this does nothing to help
us compute the inference and let me
illustrate this dramatically with a
graph in a sec so here's the graph so
again we have a we have a time and log
scale on the y-axis and what happened
here is we took the TPC data and we
injected it with probabilities in all
kinds of different ways okay and the
results are actually pretty robust
depending on how you inject the
probabilities but we made the TPC
dataset probabilistic okay on the x axis
we tried different scale factors you can
see that the scale factor one is about
approximately one gig it's actually
closer to two gigs when after you inject
all these probabilities then what we did
is we took a query out of this data set
we tried to evaluate it in three
different ways the first way we try to
evaluate it was with no view at all this
is basically just running the mystic
algorithm I told you before and having
it returned and you see that here that's
the blue bar on the side and this scales
with the size of the data okay the
second approach in red is the naive
approach so here what we did is we took
that and we just computed that table
that had the lineage formulas but we
didn't do anything else aggressive the
point to take away is that it to grows
with the size of the data it's slightly
smaller than the blue line of the blue
bar but this is eaten up by the log
scale it is a little bit faster but not
too much faster what I'm going to tell
you about next in the next few slides is
our push which is at the bottom which
performs considerably better okay you
see that it's response time is almost
constant across all the different scale
sizes and it's because we're cheating
we're actually doing the same thing that
materialized views would be doing and
that's what I'm going to tell you about
for the next couple slides okay so the
idea behind representable views are
these materialized views is kind of a
crazy one what we're going to do is
we're going to toss away those lineage
formulas and they get an intuition about
why this is so crazy these things are
essentially see tables from the 80s
right so since the 80s when people were
worried about see tables and query
processing to the 90s when fear and row
lucky we're doing their probabilistic
ir2 2001 trio and mystic were computing
these lineage formulas everyone's been
pathologic we keeping these formulas
around and what we're going to do is
we're just going to toss them out the
window
and we're going to toss them out the
window I mean we're going to compute
marginal probabilities and we're going
to pretend that the tuples in the
database actually aren't correlated okay
so we're going to try and answer queries
using the the table on the right as
opposed to the table on the left now of
course there's a catch right those
lineage formulas were doing something
what they were doing was telling us
about correlations so what we have to
prove the analysis i'm going to talked
about is that we're going to prove that
evaluating the query on this table on
the left is the same as evaluating it on
the query on the right on the table on
the right okay and the idea is that that
table is much smaller much simpler and
so we will be able to get the kind of
performance we saw in the last crap now
you may be asking at this point how can
this possibly be right how is it
possible that there are some
independence is that hold in this table
right that we can take advantage of and
let me just show you that in this simple
of this cooked up example you see that
in fact there are no tuples that are
shared between this vldb tuples and the
sigma tuples so what I mean is for the
experts that we want a static analysis
on that view description that I said it
was so important earlier to prove that
no matter what happens in the output
these large scale in dependencies will
hold and the intuition is that if a
query then comes along and only touches
you know one tuple from each of these
bins or these independent blocks then
its value will actually be correct
because it's only computing with
independent tuples and that's not what
we're assuming on the right hand side so
we want to do exactly the static
analysis of views now just a little bit
of terminology if this holds for any if
for any conjunctive query q any query
can be used in this way on top of it I'm
going to call that view representable
okay and the naming comes from the fact
that that means that essentially this
top on this table on the right hand side
looks exactly like that simplified
representation I showed you before
that's representable inside this Eid
system okay so this gets us to the key
theoretical question we need to answer
which is given a view description V is
its output going to be representable for
any input database okay and for the
experts in the room what this is is
actually a closure test for see tables
right now depending on your persuasion
this problem is either wildly
intractable or totally trivial
if you're a theoretically minded you may
look at this question and say well it's
a property of an infinite number of
databases or an unbounded number of
databases it's not even clear to me that
it's decidable right because we're just
looking at the property of the view
description now it turns out since V is
a conjunctive query it has what's called
a small model property and so in fact it
is decidable but it is wildly
intractable it is complete for this
class PI 2 p which is np-hard ok so the
theoreticians right in some respects
this is very difficult but the
practitioner says on the other hand all
these things about query containment you
told me these things were very very
difficult and very hard but in practice
actually we have heuristics that seem to
work very very well and we don't ever
have to resort to the complicated theory
so what we did here has come up with
also an approximate test which is sound
but not complete and actually we can
prove that in most practical cases it
actually is complete so the practitioner
is right as well actually in practice we
can solve this question using a simple
test based on unification okay very
similar to how containment us all now a
second thing I want to tell you is that
a representable view is one for which
every query gets the right value but it
also makes sense to consider the pair
the query and the view together right
and what we call this is a partially
representable view when only some
queries are safe if you like on top of
it are easy to evaluate and we also have
a complete theory of partially
representable views which is obviously a
superset of the theory I told you about
before and for the experts in the room
the key idea here is that we're
generalizing critical tuples ok so we're
generalizing water like thought of as
boolean derivatives and that allows us
to conclude essentially both of these
tests and we have a full theory here of
the complexity and polynomial time
approximation please what is important
is not it's not only to find out that a
particular view is
not it's also too to find out Hoffman is
it a lot of you we started if most of
the views are not represented that
there's no utility to find out if it's
not that's an excellent one so one of
the highlights of the partially
representable theory is that every view
is partially representable it's not true
that all views are representable and I
didn't include the graph here but it's
in the paper actually turns out that
most real live views for example i took
the views that were inside that company
i like that they were computing they
weren't using probabilistic databases
but you could very easily see where
there were in Precision's in their view
they were combining similarities and so
on I think it was like eighty percent of
their views were actually representable
or could benefit from these techniques
so that there was some amount of work
that could be saved but it is true that
not every it's not like materialized
views for standard regular databases
where you can materialize anything you
want but maybe it's not updateable or
something like this or not easily to
maintain here you can actually
materialized every view it's a little
bit stricter test but it's because those
correlations are messy to deal with when
you can though it's extremely efficient
you just off the lineage out the window
so that's a good point so the practical
we've gone down a little bit of a theory
hole here oh please oh we have inserted
updates so I was just mentioning this as
in the context of that's where the
materialized view stuff gets starts to
get very interesting selection and
updating but we faced an even more basic
problem here for probabilistic views I
was just trying to emphasize that yeah
so we went down a little bit of a theory
hole here there's a long digression
about PI 2 P hardness and all these
things but remember this was a very
practical thing we were motivated by we
wanted to get that graph that I showed
at the beginning where everything was
flat and constant and actually that's
what's going on here that review was
representable and the queries on top of
it of course could then be processed
much more efficiently so that was the
idea please
present ability and safe plans in that
Carlos's so they're actually orthogonal
so there are examples in all categories
that you can think of things that are
safe but not representable representable
but not safe safe and representable not
safe and not that i presentable so they
actually are orthogonal concepts there
does seem to be so one interesting
connection with safety since you brought
it up is that you can have a query which
is unsafe but after you do some
materialized view you take some sub
query and you materialize it then the
remaining part of the query if you like
is safe so answering the query on top of
that view now why is that so helpful
well you could imagine computing that
materialized view offline and doing all
the hard work offline and then your
online query processing is now very
cheap so there are somehow complementary
techniques to one another that can be
used to really build up large-scale
performance that's an excellent point so
let me summarize the technical
contributions that I've told you about
and give you one sentence summaries of
the other two okay so i told you about
top k processing and here we had the
theory so here are the red and blue are
back again and the hammers on top in
case they were the red and blue are
understated the red says that there are
two approximations right so there was a
theoretical two approximation that we
showed for the multi simulation the
practical impact of that was they we're
about two orders of magnitude whenever
we could add process these top kek works
for so for this special set we were able
to get close to relational speeds for
the materialized view problem we solve
this closure problem and practice what
this allowed us to do was materialize
these views so we could scale two
gigabytes and gigabytes of data please
yeah so I'm addicted to them yeah
conjunctive queries will make appearance
everywhere yeah exactly right the third
contribution which I didn't have time to
tell you about but I'll just summarize
in one line is that we showed this idea
of approximately nature so the idea here
is rather than just tossing away all
that lineage like we would do for
materialized view let's keep some of it
around and the art of this of this work
was that we're going to keep around just
the important parts and what we proved
is that there are always a small
important set that we can keep around
that always gets us epsilon close that's
always a good approximation okay and
what this allowed in practice
our orders of magnitude compression 100
fold compression which allows us to
scale up and is orthogonal with the
materialized view approaches okay please
are you sure the graph very five
buildings
so yeah so we did something that's
standard in the area but it's very
abusive outside we knocked out all of
the aggregations so so we took the shape
of the query and just made all converted
all aggregations and to exist right so
any time you saw a count or a sum we
replace that with an exist or a distinct
if you like to generate queries because
there aren't real workloads that and the
ones that we know about that are more
credible we can't publish so it's an
excellent technical yeah the last
contribution was going back to the
earlier point about aggregation
processing and here we have a series of
optimal algorithms and I discussed a
little bit about the fact that for
aggregation queries like with some count
and average things like you know real
sequel aggregates we have some things
that are akin to safe plans for those
type of queries and for those of course
the practical benefit is that you'll get
sequel speed processing whenever those
things apply and as I mentioned it turns
out that actually approximating them is
hard theoretically hard as well okay so
there's a more interesting theoretical
landscape for aggregate queries and
there are four standard bullying lawyers
okay okay how much time do I have so oh
okay perfect all right so I will
actually spend one or two slides on on
other systems I built okay so another
system we built how to follow an
observation not everything fits into the
model that we talked about earlier that
very simple model so what we want to
model are things like sequential
correlations and what we were motivated
here where exactly by were exactly that
RFID example right so your your location
is correlated over time very strongly
this is important to model in the
database to get the correct answers it
turns out that the sequential
probabilistic data also pop up in areas
like text parsing and audio to text okay
when you're converting audio and trying
to transcribe it you get very
similar-looking probabilistic models so
in the lard project what we want to do
is manage that kind of data and the idea
was to be able to process regular
expression like queries in both real
time so you know dirt me exactly when
someone entered the office and also
historically doing like mining queries
over this data and so an example would
be alert me when anyone enters the
lecture lecture hall after the
coffee-room right so sequential queries
that look like regular expressions but
there's an anyone in there so there's
some kind of variable or templating like
data log okay so combining the two so
the highlights of this or that the
challenge is really that we have to do
these massive data sets and again we use
the same techniques static analysis of
the queries sometimes improve sampling
routines and the indexing that I I
briefly mentioned and the contribution
of this work it was a was the first
system to support these rich structured
queries on streaming data okay and for
more information please see the lahar
website we have much improved videos and
the one I showed you here they don't
rate particle filtering but they show
you actually what's going on in the real
deployment and there's lots of fun stuff
that's on there as well to other things
I'll put the other two up there's the g
do plug stuff with arvind one other
project that I worked on was at IBM
which was much more systems oriented it
was building an XML compiler for this
thing called galaxy which was used
inside for example cell phone towers by
AT&T to check consistency of call
records and my contributions there were
actually building the algebraic compiler
inside of it you know recognizing joins
inside of xquery things like that also
on disk layout and things for
distributed query processing to do data
integration with some life scientists
people at the University of Washington
those web first project when I came in
second project which I'm happy to talk
about a little bit offline is this
declarative language for deduplication
with constraints that was we did here
last spring the theory thing just a
hammer again on the red and the blue the
theory thing was that we had a constant
factor approximation for a large
fragment of the D do blog language so we
did static analysis on the language to
prove how this is always you know within
some fixed bound for quality and the
practical is that we could cut cluster
sites here in around two minutes and if
you know this literature this is
actually quite impressive if you were to
extrapolate one other well-known
approach to the site's your data set it
would take on the order of seven CPU
years this is so this is quite an
improvement going down to two minutes
and this will be at the upcoming ICD in
Shanghai okay so now I'm going to tell
you about my future work and my vision I
have told 45 right is that correct so
not correct yeah yeah so I mean it's
fine i only have a couple more slides
okay
so let me tell you about my short-term
and medium-term work which is pushing
more on this idea of approximation which
I told you about briefly an approximate
lineage and also that idea of
compression okay so the goal here is to
manage the exabytes of data that are
being produced and the observation is
that most of the data that's going to be
produced over the next five years is
actually data that we can only
understand imprecisely things like calls
videos images so just because of the
sheer number of data or because of the
complexity of its semantics we only get
some imprecisely so since this data is
already in precise and we want to do
sophisticated querying on it and that's
very difficult perhaps we can trade off
a little bit more imprecision in the
data for a lot of query processing
performance and we've already seen one
example of this this is for example in
the lahar system we did the approximate
indexing and compression and we're able
to get orders of magnitude improvement
in performance without too much
degradation in terms of precision and
recall inquiring this is a pretty
obvious trade-off but it's a fundamental
one a second thing is that i mentioned
this i just want to come back to it we
talked about approximation for aggregate
queries these very data warehousing
style queries which are obviously
critically important to OLAP style
applications and it turns out the
high-level point that i've mentioned is
that these queries are actually provably
hard to approximate so that nice
sampling algorithm I showed you before
doesn't actually exist for these queries
now these queries are very importantly
we need to do something about them so I
think that an interesting thing that
I've talked to some people about is
combining the kind of static analysis on
the query we've done with heuristics
from statistics which has these very
great rich theory of heuristics
essentially that allow us to process
very similar-looking queries I think
this is an interesting opportunity for
future work I'll skip this one in the
interest of time and just tell you about
a long-term thing so the general feeling
that I have is that the future of data
as I mentioned these large-scale
collections of data we're actually going
to be considerably less precise than the
data we were dealing with now and as a
result the data are going to be more
difficult to understand and more
difficult to debug okay now what I would
like to provide is a database that's
able to give clear concise explanations
on data products and I think actually a
bunch of projects in the area are
actually already going in this direction
so one example of this is a paper that
was in this last cider that was talking
about how do we transfer transfer
queries the results of structured
queries to simple text right so a simple
text description of queries and people
are starting to make progress on giving
you know a précis or a very small simple
description of what a structured query
is computing the second reason to study
these explanations is that this gives
the sort of closes the loop with respect
to the providence and lineage stuff
there are a lot of scientific databases
right now where people are tracking you
know where's the provenance of this data
coming from but and worth what's the
lineage of this information but they
don't offer tools to explain it to you
they don't offer a theoretical
foundation and tell you this is a good
explanation for why this is present this
is actually an idea that we found quite
powerful in other areas such as data
mining to and debugging so this may seem
very vague and it is very far-reaching
there's no question about that but there
is some foundational work so just as
probabilities gave us a way to abstract
away the details of all these impress I
sources and get to the funnel
fundamental data management like wearing
tasks there's some fundamental work on
causality and explanation that's grown
up in the last ten years particularly by
pearl and Halpern that will allow us to
treat all these explanations in a
uniform way and the interesting part is
that the competitive advantage I have is
that these techniques are in precise
right so all the techniques to deal with
causality and explanation actually rely
on large scale and precision processing
which is essentially what my
dissertation is about so it's a natural
extension so the last thing I want to
tell you about is some related work this
is a this is and to be blunt be the
message here is that publicity databases
are important there are a lot of people
studying them so here's here's lists
okay so in the probabilistic discrete
relational case in recent memory there
have been three systems that are coming
out there's our system mystic which was
the first the trio system which did a
lot of great modeling of how imprecision
should be modeled and also was the one
who identified the concept of lineage as
a very first important first class
concept a follow-on project is the maybe
a mess system by Christophe call where
he has in some ways extended our results
for example on safe plans to scale up to
really large data sets as well so at
Cornell and Oxford with Daniel Tiana and
some of their students now in this talk
I talked talked only about these
discrete representations you know the it
was in the conference or wasn't in the
conference
but for things like temperature you want
continuous representations and people
have looked at that as well a full
credit goes to the Orion project at
Purdue who were looking at this along
the same time about the same time was
the barb the very famous barbecue
project that was looking at acquisition
or query processing for sensor networks
and temperatures one very interesting
project is this MC DB which is taking
place at Rice Florida and IBM and the
idea here is that forget about all this
static analysis for the moment trying to
figure out which queries are safe which
views are materialized let's just use
sampling to answer every query but do
the sampling very very efficiently so
these guys are statisticians and they're
have making some very interesting
progress doing these things and Peter
house and I have had some conversations
about perhaps going you know combining
static analysis with these statistical
techniques it's a it's a very
interesting and wide open area to do
this stuff at really large scales
because the problem they have there is
performance sampling just is very very
difficult to scale to real sequel
queries and real datasets they're also a
series of approaches on graphical models
that have come out over the last little
while from the AI community mostly into
the database community where they treat
the database query answering problem as
an inference problem this is certainly a
well established in great area of work
another thing I wanted emphasize is we
talked about top k processing and i made
this bold claim that top k processing is
fundamental to probabilities and to back
that up actually there are a bunch of
people working on top KS plus ranking
I've listed some there but every time
you pick up a proceeding there's at
least one or two papers that have to do
with pick your favorite ranking pick
your favorite semantic and pick your
favorite top K and put them together and
the reason is is it turns out that it's
a surprisingly interesting paradigm to
support a lot of nice fun applications
so people are looking at that in full
credit should go to e hab ilyas at
waterloo and his student mohammed
solomon who actually proposed adding
ranking functions not just looking for
the most probable tuples as was
mentioned here but looking for a sort of
you know arbitrarily best tuples and
it's surprisingly subtle problem and its
most general formulation and there's
also work on streaming probabilistic
databases one I want to mention is the
UMass project with the iron lady ow and
here the idea is that they want to
process radar databases and they're very
very cool but the problem is the amount
of data is orders of magnitude greater
than the kind of data that we deal with
in Lahore so the techniques about
particle filtering and all those things
we don't apply so there's an entire
world of big data out there there are
also very cool techniques from AI we
borrow their models extension
extensively and we're trying to import
some of their techniques notably
differential inference and lifted
inference which have very similar
analogues to the kind of stuff we're
doing and are both very awesome okay so
to conclude what did I want you to take
away from this talk if you took away
nothing else the first thing is that
there are a growing number of large
impress I status ettes okay there are a
lot of these applications out there and
they're profitable to manage the second
thing is that if you're going to model
in precision a promising approaches to
use probabilities and this allows us to
strip off sort of the differences
between these different applications and
really get to the fundamental parts of
them the third pragmatic thing I want
you to take away is that it's possible
to actually build these applications on
really large scale databases we saw here
dealing with gigabytes of data which is
difficult for probabilistic processing
but we were able to do it the key
challenge to get there was performance
and my contribution was really about
scale told you about materialized views
i told you about top k processing and
those things and the theme of my work
was always doing some amount of theory
or some amount of formal work to get
some practical results and in here the
practical results were always that we
wanted to process on gigabytes and
gigabytes of data so thank you very much
for your time I appreciate your great
audience